les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que en esta
ocasión nos lleva a uno de los
considerados principales santuarios de
terrorismo mundial y que se encuentra en
fase de normalización las zonas tribales
paquistaníes en la zona fronteriza con
afganistán este pedazo de tierra fue
durante mucho tiempo desestabilizado por
los grupos islamistas radicales que
operaban allí con total impunidad en la
medida en que la ley de islamabad la
capital pakistaní no se aplicaba en las
zonas tribales tras los atentados del 11
de septiembre de 2001 estos oscuros o
territorios de transformó en uno de los
desafíos de la llamada guerra contra el
terrorismo tras una masacre en una
escuela militar que le costó la vida a
132 niños en peshawar en 2014 el
ejército paquistaní lanzó una ofensiva
para sacar a los grupos armados de las
zonas tribales la operación generó más
de un millón de desplazados internos en
total la guerra contra el terrorismo en
pakistán provocó 70.000 muertes y miles
de desaparecidos en marzo de 2018 el
gobierno paquistaní anunció la fusión
completa de las zonas tribales pero esta
medida logrará pacificar la región para
siempre
[Música]
waziristán del norte una tierra árida y
escarpada
uno de los siete distritos que componen
las zonas tribales paquistaníes hasta
marzo de 2018 la constitución de
pakistán no se aplicaba en este
territorio regido por leyes
tradicionales
desde entonces tuvo lugar una fusión una
elección oficial de las zonas tribales
al estado paquistaní con el fin de
pacificar esta violenta región
[Música]
hay células terroristas que siguen
operando ahí la presencia militar sigue
siendo visible
y esas cosas
lamentable
lp
neutralizamos bombas en todo el norte de
waziristán recorremos todas las
carreteras y escaneamos el suelo para
encontrarme minas artesanales bombas
etcétera
leer
entre 2010 y 2011 para nosotros era
imposible estar aquí y hablar así muy
arriesgado los habitantes estaban
cortados del mundo física y mentalmente
es por ello que las actividades
criminales y el tráfico de drogas
prosperaban en aquella época era normal
que robaran vehículos los pagos por
rescates también
ahora los civiles caminan y conducen
aquí
hay intercambios comerciales es una
prueba de cambio
a unos cuantos metros de aquí camiones
vienen de afganistán
etc
recientemente confiscamos municiones
en algunos vehículos también encontramos
hachís y otros estupefacientes
construida en 2017 una cerca sobre más
de 2.000 kilómetros separa afganistán de
pakistán
según el ejército pakistaní recorre más
del 80% de la frontera una frontera
hasta ahora porosa donde transitaban
impunemente grupos terroristas como los
talibanes al qaeda o el estado islámico
en corazón esas idas y venidas siguen
teniendo lugar pero han disminuido
este es nuestro sistema de alerta
mejorado y las líneas de detección pasan
por aquí contamos con una sala de
control captores de 30 a 40 metros y
cuando alguien se aproxima a la cerca
recibimos una alarma hubo una afluencia
de insurgentes de afganistán hacia acá
pero ahora es casi imposible que la
gente pueda pasar de hacer que
si algún grupo trata de hacerlo le
disparamos seguiremos las órdenes y
protegeremos la cerca a cualquier presa
tras años de laxismo los combates entre
los ejércitos y los grupos terroristas
del lado paquistaní se endurecieron en
2014 tras una masacre perpetrada en una
escuela militar en peshawar el ejército
paquistaní lanzó en ese entonces vastas
campañas militares en waziristán y
acompañó de este esfuerzo de guerra con
una amplia operación de comunicación
con el paso de los años los militares
reunieron los objetos encontrados en
escondites yihadistas e hicieron un
museo el coronel cameron nos propone una
visita guiada
estamos aquí en una reconstrucción de un
cuartel general de terroristas
encontramos 300 de diferentes tamaños en
el norte de waziristán
reunimos todo el equipo y los objetos
encontrados en sus escondites
este es un un visado por los talibanes
que le quitaron el ejército
estadounidense en afganistán y trajeron
aquí hace parte de lo que hemos
confiscado
esta es la sala de preparación de los
suicidas
completo del paraíso
un ataque suicida que lo mantenía aquí
durante unos días y se le mostraba
paraíso sería bello como esto
que habría ríos de vino justo después
del ataque suicida joven abriera los
ojos vería una bella mujer de pie con
sus brazos cubiertos para acogerlo
en el muro hay poemas rosas y afiches de
estrellas de bollywood
debajo de estos tapetes eran excavadas
puertas de túneles cuando había un
bombardeo por parte de nuestras tropas
ingresaban a esos túneles
si alguien era herido lo ajustaban en
esta cama había equipo médico pueden ver
diferentes medicamentos curas
esta era la sala de prisioneros pueden
ver sus diferentes herramientas de
tortura para encadenar al capturado
atarle las manos los pies graban a
nuestros soldados o jefes tribales que
apoyaban el gobierno los traían aquí los
amarraban les cortaban la garganta aquí
la sangre corría por aquí
en 2004 la primera vez que vine aquí
era capitán en ese momento la situación
era horrible la gente estaba la bandera
paquistaní le cortaban la cabeza
la violencia ha disminuido pero hay
grupos que siguen haciendo atentados en
estas regiones el pasado mes de febrero
cuatro trabajadoras sociales fueron
asesinadas en el norte de waziristán
en peshawar la gran ciudad paquistaní
cercana a las zonas tribales la
seguridad también ha mejorado
con el paso de los años el acceso a la
educación y a un estilo de vida más
liberal se ha desarrollado una hits
afridi originaria de las zonas tribales
se instaló ahí vivo aquí en la casa de
mi hermana porque alrededor de la zona
privada no es fácil ser aceptada como
una mujer soy miembro de un partido
político de izquierda pretende
presentarse a las elecciones locales
este año elecciones inéditas hasta 2018
ninguna votación ha tenido lugar en las
zonas tribales la hits debe ir hoy al
distrito tribal de bagà para una reunión
política
orden del día la toma del poder por
parte de los talibanes en afganistán
vecino y las dificultades que se han
acumulado contra un estado paquistaní
que no respeta sus promesas
estoy muy preocupada por la situación en
afganistán tenemos suficientes
dificultades ya vivimos mal nuestras
casas siguen destruidas por la guerra
cómo podemos absorber el flujo de
refugiados afganos esto va a crear
muchos problemas teniendo en cuenta que
nuestro sistema es bastante frágil que
podemos proponer
es lo que le pedimos al gobierno
provincial a quienes ya les cuesta
ocuparse de nosotros como podrán
facilitar la llegada de refugiados
sabe que no cuentan con medios para
hacerlo incluso la compensación
financiera prometida tras la fusión no
ha llegado es muy cierto señora cuando
las zonas tribales fueron fusionadas con
la provincia vecina en virtud de una
nueva enmienda constitucional
prometieron que más de 500 millones de
euros serían entregados anualmente
durante los diez años siguientes a
nuestro territorio pero hace tres años
que recibimos mucho menos normalmente
sólo los hombres se sientan en este tipo
de asambleas porque es un espacio de
decisión fui la primera mujer en hacer
parte de estas asambleas y cuando
circularon fotos de ellas mucha gente
dijo que era el resultado de la fusión
si una mujer desafiaba nuestra
organización tribal debía ejecutar gente
empezó a criticar a mi partido
preguntaban cómo había podido hacer
parte de una asamblea una reunión o una
campaña electoral preguntaban por qué un
hombre no ocupaba mi lugar
una de las misiones de la jeta freddy en
el partido proponer proyectos que
mejoren las condiciones de vida rudas de
las mujeres de las zonas tribales hoy
visita la única comisaría de la policía
exclusivamente femenina hace parte de
algunas estructuras gubernamentales que
han surgido desde la fusión
deseo que estas comisarías para mujeres
puedan surgir en otros distritos
tribales fusionados nuestras mujeres
tribales no están muy seguras
y si cuentan con ese servicio tendrán
coraje e irán a denunciar sus problemas
en las comisarías para mujeres
normalmente qué casos llegan allí
la mayoría del tiempo los asuntos están
relacionados con problemas en el hogar
conflictos inmobiliarios violencia
doméstica
mi marido me golpea
la golpeó recientemente sí anoche sigue
borracho a veces en la noche nos saca de
la casa mis hijos también están muy
perturbados por su culpa
incluso los vecinos están cansados de él
entonces vine aquí para pedir ayuda
quiero que sea detenido porque nuestra
vida es miserable a su lado
una cultura muy misógina dominada en
efecto las zonas tribales
sus habitantes en su mayoría
pertenecientes a la etnia pastún
defienden los valores del honor y la
virilidad
en el mercado de ver a la venta de armas
es una costumbre que se perpetúa de
padre a hijo aquí no se exige ningún
permiso de porte de armas ni a los
compradores ni a los vendedores
este viejo modelo era cercano a la
perfección antes la gente guardaba sus
armas con cuidado con las protegían con
cuero había una pasión y un apego a su
arma un mercado de armas en regulación
salvo para los grandes calibres a que la
normalización de las zonas tribales
deseada por el gobierno no ha sido
consolidada ni es popular
la fusión no trajo ninguna ventaja para
nosotros no nos dio nada
javier no quitó cosas teníamos una bella
cultura y un sistema tribal de varios
siglos
[Música]
entera una kalashnikov cuesta menos que
un teléfono
cuánto cuesta esa pistola cien euros
porque está costosa es una copia de un
arma europea
seguro si se caen o se rompen
no no se lo garantizo me gusta la
calificó porque es un arma confiable
puede ser fabricada fácilmente aquí los
suspiros son fluidos en el pasado había
una gran demanda de esta arma en
afganistán
y cuando se le pregunta si aún exporta
armas a afganistán el hombre deja de
hablar
no me pregunten nada sobre aumenta no sé
nada no me involucre no es un tema del
que se deba hablar aquí
dispara algunos cartuchos y verifica que
todo esté bien
se sospecha que islamabad juega doble
con los buenos y malos talibanes como se
les llama en pakistán
el ejército combate a los talibanes
paquistaníes en su territorio pero se
sospecha que sus servicios secretos
apoyan a los fundamentalistas en el lado
afgano
nos reunimos con la guita freddy
dirigiéndose a una escuela de niñas en
la zona tribal llevar a una región
golpeada por los talibanes paquistaníes
en el pasado
salam cómo estás estoy bien y tú bien
esta escuela había sido destruida por
los insurgentes
si fue completamente destruida empezó
cuando los talibanes nos dijeron que no
debíamos venir a la escuela solo con
velo y que debíamos llevar el burka nos
dijeron que debíamos traer hombres de
nuestra familia para escoltar nos les
respondimos que trabajábamos y que
podíamos traer hombres para trabajar en
2008 la situación empeoró los talibanes
amenazaron numerosas escuelas como la
nuestra y las destruyeron
ozawa
[Música]
menos del 8% de las mujeres de las zonas
tribales han sido alfabetizadas
bajit quieres sensibilizar a las niños
de su tierra natal para la acción
política
hola niñas cómo están cuántos de ustedes
las niñas se volverán políticas pastor
guau cantas lideresas mi señora podría
ser muy difícil porque es muy difícil
llegar a la política en esta región
siempre es difícil al principio la
primera vez que una niña ha salido de
casa para ir a la escuela todo el mundo
hablaba mal de ella elgeta decía que iba
en contra del agua y finalmente cuando
empezó a ir a la escuela otras lo
hicieron también todo el mundo hablaba
mal de la primera mujer media pero ahora
todas las niñas desean ser de siempre
habla mal de aquellos que hacen algo por
primera vez pero luego la sociedad
acepta que al final los obstáculos
disminuirán para las niñas como ustedes
pero los obstáculos aún son numerosos en
la normalización de la región entre los
atentados que persisten el juego doble
del ejército pakistaní y un gobierno que
no honra sus promesas de desarrollo
sigue habiendo desconfianza mutua en las
zonas tribales
[Música]
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta a las zonas tribales de
pakistán recuerde que si quiere ver
estos y otros contenidos en español
puede visitar nuestra página web
france24 puntocom hasta pronto